foreign
and welcome to this video on top devops
certification for 2023 by simply learn
in this video we will clear your doubt
regarding the bad devop certification
you can choose to enter or advance in
your career as a devops engineer but
before we begin if you enjoy watching
these type of videos and find them
interesting then subscribe to our
YouTube channel as we bring out your
best videos daily also hit the Bell icon
to never miss any update from Simply
learn so let's get started the tech
industry is evolving rapidly and Company
is now prioritizing efficiency
scalability and deployment divorce
Bridges the gaps between development and
organization teams ensuring seamless
collaboration faster development cycles
and quicker releases in 2023 businesses
are seeking Innovative solution to meet
the ever-changing demands of customer
and that's where devops comes into play
it enables organization to deliver
faster high quality product faster
ultimately increasing customer
satisfaction and maximizing profit so if
you want to stay ahead of the curve and
be the part of tech evolution devops is
the way to go do you know guys that
devops engineer working in the United
States earns around 120 000 per annum
and the same devops engineer in India
earns around 8 lakh rupees annually
that's not the salary of a lead devops
engineer a lead devops engineer salary
can go up to 172 000 in the United
States and 22 lakh rupees per year in
India so moving forward let's see some
devops engineer roles and
responsibilities
now that we know why devops is a hot
career choice let's explore the rules
and responsibilities of a devops
engineer as a devops engineer you will
be better at the heart of the
development and operation process
driving collaboration and efficiency
your primary responsibility will include
the first one is continuous integration
and deployment you will Design Implement
and manage automated pipeline to enable
frequent and reliable code deployments
the second one is infrastructure
management devops Engineers are
responsible for managing and scaling the
infrastructure including Cloud resources
and on-premises system the third one is
monitoring and troubleshooting and
shooting the smooth functioning of
application and identifying and
resolving issues promptly the fourth one
is security and compliance implementing
security measures and ensuring
compliance with industrial standards and
regulations the fifth one is
collaboration and communication
fascinating effective communication
between deployment operation and other
teams to ensure a smooth workflow the
sixth one is tooling and automation
selecting and implementing the right
tools and Technologies to automate
processes and optimize development
workflows the last one is performance
optimization continuously analyzing and
improving system in performance to
enhance user experience remember a
devops engineer is not just a role it's
a mindset of continuous Improvement and
Innovation so moving forward let's see
some skills required for a devops
engineer excited about the opportunity
devops offers grid now let's talk about
the skills you will need to become a
successful devops engineer the first one
is coding and scripting strong knowledge
of programming languages like python
rupee or JavaScript and descriptive
skills are essential for automation
tools and development the second one is
system administration familiarity with
Linux Unix and the Windows systems
including configuration and
troubleshooting the third one is cloud
computing
Proficiency in Cloud platforms like AWS
Azure or Google Cloud to deploy and
manage applications in the cloud fourth
one is containerization and organization
understanding container Technologies
like Docker and container organization
tools like kubernetes is a must the
first one is continuous integration and
deployment experience with CI CD tools
such as Jenkins gitlab Ci or Circle CI
to automate the development workflow the
sixth one is infrastructure s code IAC
knowledge of IAC tools like data form or
ansible to manage infrastructure
programmatically the last one is
monitoring and logic familiarity with
monitoring tools like promo tiers
grafana and lodging Solutions like elk
stack acquiring these skills will not
only make you a valuable devops engineer
but will also open doors to exciting job
opportunities so the model of this video
is to help you guys choose the right
course to enter or advance in devops in
the future on that note we introduce you
the postgraduate program in devops by
simply learn if you are eager to become
devops engineer and Propel your career
to new heights and simply run
postgraduate program in devops is
undoubtedly the right choice for you
devops training course design in
collaboration with Caltech ctme is a
professional development option that
will Square your skill with the industry
and standards our Cutting Edge Blended
learning combines live online devops
certification classes with interactive
Labs that will give you hands-on
experience the comprehensive devops
training codes will unlock your true
potential providing you with a solid
foundation and formalization and
documenting development processes along
with creating a self document system the
program will nurture your expertise in
advanced tools like puppet salt egg pan
and civil enabling you to achieve self
governments and automatic management at
scale conceptual completion you will
earn the coveted Caltech CDMA
postgraduate certificate a testament to
your expertise in the devops domain so
start your devops journey by taking your
step-by-step post-graduate program in
devops that will prepare you for a
devops engineer roles thanks to a
comprehensive curriculum covering
everything such as get GitHub Docker
cscd with Jenkins kubernetes and much
more join our Vibrant Community of
devops professionals who have harnessed
the power of Simply learn postgraduate
program to accelerate their career check
out the links mentioned in the
description box below and enroll now to
become a successful devops engineer
thank you for joining us today to
explore the world of devops and the
incredible career opportunity it present
remember the tech industry is evolving
rapidly and devops is the key to staying
ahead in the game so don't hesitate to
embrace this exciting career path if you
found this video helpful please give it
a thumbs up and subscribe to our YouTube
channel for more exciting Tech related
content if you have any question or want
to share your thoughts drop a comment
below until next time happy learning I
will see you again
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign